of all the haunted house moves scary
movie things that the lame brothers have
done that whoever took over in a scary
movie franchise whatever this is
probably the funniest one of them I'm
not sure that means anything it just is
what it is a haunted house too so
haunted house too you know exactly what
a haunted house too is it's another one
of those spooky movies that spoof scary
movies and here we are you've seen these
movies a hundred times over they're
never good they're never funny they're
never clever they just are the simplest
form of entertainment for that lizard
part of your brain however I was kind of
surprised with this one because there
were a few times in his movie I was
laughing not saying this moves good no
it's still a tasteless cinematic
abomination and it made me laugh and I
got to give credit where credit's due if
a movie like this makes me laugh it's
educational apparently the term for a
bunch of black dudes jail raping a
really pasty old white guy is dirtying
the snow I'm gonna go to hell yeah there
were tasteless moments in the to the
receives rum like this is going on way
too long and this isn't funny because
it's not clever way to feed the scenes
but pretty much every scene in the movie
went on for far too long if you just
stop when it was funny take my laughter
as a win and move on to the next scene
know that kept going and going and going
thing and they can make it funnier and
it's just it makes it worse a humor can
be found in these really subtle moments
I mean what were someone impersonates
Forest Whitaker because he has the eye
thing a lion here a reference here
there's actually one scene that went on
for far too long I didn't want to laugh
and the more I tried not to laugh the
harder I laughed I'd avoid this movie I
looked over to my friend I was like
alright is it that we're Dumber or is
this movie actually kind of funny it was
like I know right so either the anomaly
is that two people are becoming stupid
or stupid movies becoming less stupid I
choose to believe the second one cuz it
helps my case
yeah it's dumb humor is toilet humor if
you go into this movie all ideas are not
those cinematic experience is hoping for
to it off' or not going to happen not
here in fact if you go into this movie
expecting to use your brain
pretty much at all yeah you're gonna
walk out going now and to be clear I'm
not saying the movies good I did not say
that I'm not advocating the movie it's
not worth paying all your money for I'm
just saying there was humor sprinkled in
this movie where I was like yeah it's
funny a lot
our moments that we're not funny I just
can't deny the physical fact that the
movie made me laugh a few times I'm
saying a haunted house too would
probably be really fun if you're drunk
yeah and now it's a party
a dirty in the snow that's [ __ ] up
which is more than I can say for any one
of these haunted house spoof scary movie
things I saw haunted house - have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more
[Music]